check this out Danny I blame apple for
this trend in gadget products or get a
gadget packaging because look at this
Apple started this whole trend of
putting things in these fantastically
complicated beautiful packages and now
monster cable thinks I have to do the
same thing with these beats headphones
Oh beats by dre beats by dre I love
being a library not beat downs by dre
ibeats these are pretty high on
headphones um and I have to say they
sound good they sound damn good they got
a lot of help estate yeah really solid
base yeah and I have to say the sound
quality is amazingly good they're pretty
uh pretty sound isolating you put them
on your on your ears and really really
sharp quality sound their noise
cancelling as well yes and I did the
blow dryer test last night uh-huh and
they matched my bose QC 3 headphones
that's good in noise cancellation that's
really good fantastic the one thing I
will say is that they're a little bit
muddy towards the middle this air and so
I mean you get really good high as you
get amazingly good base but the the
middle frequencies are a little bit um
right muddy I feel like they were a
little menu they're like muddy waters so
now look let's see beats by dre made by
monster cable that's right I'm guessing
that they're gonna cost a whole lot of
money just like other monster cable
products in those words yes they're
going to cost through here fifty dollars
which is actually about the same as a
pair of hobos louis canceling headset
all right beats by dre excellent
high-end headphones really good sound
quality especially if you want to listen
to something that's really Basie and
thumpy um 350 bucks monster cable good
stuff
so don't you want to know my favorite
phone from CIA was oh that's samsung
something right yeah it was called the
the samsung magic touch uh-huh look what
I got with me that's the samsung magic
too sure is it's called a magical touch
because our magic touch because it has
this oled screen on it it's touch touch
compatible so it's like a little little
touch pad thing here is actually its own
kind of display right exactly that
reconfigures as you as you press it
writing present right so what it does is
it the buttons actually change depending
on the application that you're in so if
you go to say the music application
it'll change to fast-forward rewind
pause and play I like this yeah I
actually really like this display
because I think it looks really elegant
it's easy to use but it sort of seems
like they only went halfway with this
display yes they didn't use their whole
ass on this one exactly like you still
have to you still have these soft
buttons here soft buns are these are
actually real buttons or not they're not
party olin and so it gets a little
confusing it feels like they should have
put the OLED over the entire display
right there right would be pretty cool
right because instead of saying select
or menu up here and you have to press
that corresponding button if the oulad
went all the way around there all you
have to do is just press you know could
just say menu right there and you check
out the Manning part we've been fine how
is it as a phone as I thought it works
pretty well um got great quality it has
a 5 megapixel camera on it I like Wesley
yeah it takes great pictures but the
thing is is that too in order to take a
picture you have to slide it up like so
hmm and that's a little bit annoying
that's a minor annoyance it's not the
prettiest side of that camera the part
the backside this is this baby does not
have back so this is the Samsung magic
touch and it's available for how much of
500 US dollars excellent yes that's
without a contract okay so should be a
little bit cheaper from your local
carrier
you